[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM: Thanks, again for
coming and please join me
as we give a warm
welcome to Kate O'Neill.
[APPLAUSE]
KATE O'NEILL: Thanks very much.
Thank you, Tim.
Thank you, everyone.
Hello, fellow humans.
Wait, actually, I guess I
should check and make sure,
are there any robots here?
Any robots?
Raise your hand if you're
a robot in the audience.
I don't see any, so I think
we're safe to proceed.
But I ask this
question every once
in a while, because I figure,
one of these days, that it's
going to be kind of a little
spindly, mechanical arm that
comes up when I
ask that question.
I'm not really sure what I'm
supposed to do at that moment,
if I'm supposed to invite the
robot to come up here and take
my job, because that's kind
of how we talk about robots
and automation and AI
and everything these days
is like, with this fear,
this dread about what it's
going to mean for human
jobs, for humanity,
for existential
reality as we know it.
So my premise has been
to think about how
we can make technology
better for humanity, better
for our future, and
of course, better
for serving business purposes.
But in doing so, I think
we have to start back
from one of the squares,
one of the foundations,
and that is to think about
what it is that makes us human.
What is it that
makes humans human?
So I'll ask you to
indulge me and just
think for a moment of a
word or a characteristic
that you feel really captures
the human experience.
What one characteristic is it?
And I won't have you
call it out or anything
but just hold it in
your head for a moment.
What do you feel like it is
that really makes humans human?
And so let me ask, how many
of you, by a show of hands,
thought of something like
creativity or problem
solving or innovation
or something like that?
Anyone?
No one?
A couple people in the room.
Good.
So that's a pretty
common answer.
This is a more common
answer, I think,
empathy or love or compassion.
Anyone?
A few more hands.
Those are both great, I
think-- great characteristics
and admirable
qualities of humans.
I didn't necessarily
specify that these
needed to be uniquely
human attributes.
But I do think, if
we think about those,
they don't feel like
they are uniquely human.
We've seen creativity
and problem
solving in non-human
animals, like otters bang
mollusks on rocks to open
them, and ravens use tools.
And we've seen
compassion and love
from elephants and
dogs and other species.
So we know that those are
exhibited by other animals.
And I don't think
it's too far fetched
to imagine that in the
not too distant future,
we might see at least
superficial indications
of machines exhibiting
those kinds of qualities
in their behavior interactions
with humans and maybe even,
eventually, other machines,
which will be very
interesting at a surface level.
But how many of
you, when you think
about what that most
human of characteristics
is, thought of checking a box?
Anyone, by a show of hands?
Of course, you didn't,
because it's absurd.
But this is the
premise, the problem
that we encounter in
technology a lot of the time
is that we don't
necessarily think
through this kind of
foundational experience.
And we are presenting
absurdities
as if they are
foundational truths.
And besides which,
if we were to try
to claim that this is a
uniquely human characteristic,
we'd get beat out anyway
by machines that can also
do this characteristic.
So I don't know how
many of you have
seen this little [INAUDIBLE]
guy, but he's kind of fun.
[LAUGHTER]
So I have come to be known
as, as Tim mentioned,
the tech humanist.
And I take this moniker
pretty seriously,
because I feel like there
is this area around which
technology does
have the capacity
to solve human problems.
It also has the
capacity to scale,
like we are experiencing
automation and AI and all kinds
of other emerging
technologies, bringing scale
to the types of solutions
we create like never before.
And so I think it behooves
us to really think
about what the human
experience around that scale
is going to be and what
the human experience
around technology is going to be
and how we can make technology
better solve business problems
and solve human problems
at the same time.
So as I talk about
being a tech humanist
and as I think about
solving those challenges,
I'm excited that you
all are in this room
and are on the livestream and
watching on the video later,
I hope.
And then I want to
offer that, perhaps,
that that is also you, that you
maybe also are a tech humanist.
And I'd like to offer
that term to you,
so that when you see my book--
as Tim mentioned,
it just came out
September 24, "Tech Humanist"--
that you will see
that title and think,
I'm describing you as well,
because that is the truth.
I'd like to see us all
join hands in this movement
to create more human technology
and more wide-scale human
experiences that are
more meaningful and more
integrated and more dimensional
with the technology we create.
So the premise
there is, how can we
both make technology
better for business,
to solve business challenges,
and make it better for humans?
And I think that that
both, and framing
is the key to the whole thing.
We need to understand how to
accept that these things do
need to be integrated together.
And I would propose that the
way to accomplish this at scale
is to focus on creating more
meaningful human experiences
at scale.
So how do we focus on
getting that meaning
into the human experiences?
So the way that that looks
in the model that I propose
is this.
On one hand, how can we
think about scaling business
meaningfully through data,
through strategic alignment
and automation?
How can we think about using
the tools at our disposal
to make business more
effective, while also creating
more meaningful
human experiences
and scaling those through
data and automation?
I've had the opportunity
to test this idea
with a lot of
different companies
that I've consulted with,
spoken with, advised,
worked with on different
projects over the years.
And I'm excited to say that it
works in almost every industry
I've encountered.
It provides great results
no matter who you are
or what you're
trying to accomplish.
Every company is trying
to achieve profit.
Every company is trying to
achieve revenue-based metrics
in what they're going about.
Even if you're a
non-profit organization,
you still have to be accountable
to some sort of profit and loss
scenario.
There's some sort of
breakdown of the financials
that you need to
be accountable for.
And I'm happy to tell you
that the work of creating
meaningful experiences actually
does lead to increased employee
retention, decreased customer
acquisition cost, increased
loyalty, and all kinds of
other directional metrics
that lead to more profit.
Of course, it's also
the right thing to do.
It also creates a better
experience for all of us.
And I want everybody
to be motivated
by this aesthetic of wanting
the world to be better
and creating more meaningful
experiences being its own end.
But if we have to be motivated
by profit, we can be,
and that's all a
good thing, too.
So let's unpack this
just a little bit,
what I mean when I
talk about creating
meaningful human
experiences at scale.
What does that entail?
So first, let's think about
what meaningful really is.
So the example of the click the
box to confirm your humanity,
I mentioned, I think, that
that's an absurd example.
And I have this running
hobby of appreciating
the tension between meaning
and absurdity in the world.
But I feel like anywhere
there is a lack of meaning,
it opens up this void into
which absurdity can flow.
So where we don't create
enough meaning, where
we don't describe
enough meaning,
we allow absurdity to flourish.
So there is enough opportunity
for that in technology
as it is and business, really.
I think you all probably
have this experience,
I'm guessing, that
there are areas where--
let's say, you talk
about work things in ways
that you wouldn't talk
about with your friends
outside of work.
You use language or
terminology that your friends
who don't work with you
would not understand.
Or there are things that you
do at work that just don't--
that are kind of like, that's
the way we've always done it.
But any time you
think to yourself,
this doesn't make sense,
that's a really big clue,
because making things makes
sense is what meaning does.
So we have an opportunity to
step back and assess absurdity
and recognize that we can infuse
meaning into those structures
and create more opportunity
to avoid meaning,
to keep away from meaning.
So the reason that
that works, I believe,
is because humans
crave meaning more
than any other characteristic.
So if you were to ask me what
I think makes humans human,
this is what it is--
is that we seek meaning.
In all areas of life, we
are compelled by meaning.
If you offer us a meaningful
answer or solution,
we are compelled by it.
How many of you are
Douglas Adams fans?
Anyone?
A few.
So you already know where
I'm going to go with this.
In the "Hitchhiker's Guide
to the Galaxy" series,
the answer to the
great question of life,
the universe, and
everything was--
AUDIENCE: 42.
KATE O'NEILL: 42, of course.
So Douglas Adams wrote
or said in interviews
that he chose 42 because it was
not too high and not too low
of a number and because
it was just funny.
It is.
But I don't know
if you know this,
but on Reddit,
you can find this.
And a few other places
collected around the web,
there are collections of
alternate explanations
for why 42 actually
kind of makes sense
as the explanation of
meaning in the world.
So for example, there are
42 characters in the phrase,
it's the answer to life, the
universe, and everything.
So you're convinced now, right?
Also, there's 42 dots
on a pair of dice,
so that answers everything,
which I thought was just a
throw away explanation.
But my husband
said, well, life is
kind of like a roll of the
dice, so I thought, well,
all right, fair enough.
My favorite of them is this.
42 is apparently the
Unicode character--
Unicode value for the
asterisk character,
which as you may know, is
a wild card symbol, often,
in computing, which means
it can mean anything.
It's obviously
just a coincidence,
because Douglas Adams
didn't mean it that way.
AUDIENCE: That makes
it sound better.
[INAUDIBLE]
KATE O'NEILL: But that's
the important point,
is that even though Douglas
Adams didn't mean it
that way and it is
just a coincidence,
it is an absurd and poetic
and beautiful coincidence.
But we always make
meaning the way
we have always done
and always will,
which is by ascribing
different significance
to different events, based on
how and much we value them,
or in other words, by
making it up as we go along.
And I think that's the
encouraging thing about this,
is that even though
we talk about robots
and automation and AI
in the broad mainstream
in a scary way,
what this suggests
is that there is this open
interpretation to the future.
We get to make meaning for
the future as we go along.
We get to decide the
future as we go along.
You get to decide the
future as you go along.
And that's really incredible,
because right now,
the possibilities,
the power of what's
happening within technology and
within the scale of emerging
technologies, means that
we have the capacity
to create the best futures
for the most people.
There's really this
potential and, I
think, even an ethical
responsibility,
to think about how solutions
can scale to that sort of level.
So let's go back to
unpack and create
meaningful human
experiences at scale
and what is it that human
experiences really describes.
We talk a lot in business
about customer experience, user
experience, or depending
on your industry,
it may be patient
or guest or visitor
experience, student experience.
We don't often, in
many industries,
talk about human experience
in this integrated way,
in this way that brings
all of those roles together
and appreciates
the fact that there
is this kind of holistic
human experience
that transcends any of
those roles, that you are--
we are all of those roles
at any given point in time.
And so even though
you may be performing
as a customer in a
customer experience,
you are still a human coming
into that customer experience.
The important thing about that
is the transcendent empathy
that can come from
understanding the baggage,
the context that someone
brings to that interaction.
So there's an
opportunity to create
these more dimensional
interactions, these more
integrated interactions.
And so to create more
meaningful human interactions,
it turns out, we
need to design more
integrated human experiences.
We need to think about how
to blend all of those roles
and understandings together and
bring an understanding of where
someone has been, where you're
meeting them in the world,
and how you can create
these kinds of senses
of dimension and holism.
So I promised a Venn
diagram to a friend earlier,
and I have it, the best Venn
diagram in the entire world.
I'm sure you all have seen this.
If you haven't, you'll want to
rush out and get this t-shirt
right away.
Tenso Graphics makes
this Venn diagram.
But the illustration
here, really, I
think, gets at the point.
When you think about
what is possible on one
side of an equation,
such as the best
technology or the technology
to make business better,
and what's possible on the
other side of equation,
like what's possible to make
technology better for humans,
it's only by really thinking
about the intersection
of those things that you really
come at the best solutions,
like platypus keytar.
You don't get platypus
keytar until you're
doing some serious both, anding,
so that's the opportunity.
And really, what
we're talking about
is augmenting human experience
with data and context.
So the broader opportunity,
in a technology sense,
is to really think
about, where are you
meeting someone in the world?
What data do you have to
understand and appreciate
where they come from, what
their preferences are,
what their tastes are?
And how can you create context
that addresses the objectives
that you have as a
business and the objectives
they have as a
human and the role
that you're meeting them
in and the alignment
of those objectives?
How can we come at that in
a way that provides that?
And so I actually
kind of think of this
in a way as being meaning
as a service, in a sense.
It's an opportunity to
think about offering up
a meaningful
construct that aligns
your objective and
their objective
and providing the
hooks, in a sense,
to be able to expand upon that.
And I really mean any
meaning of meaning.
So meaning, as we talk about
it, could be at any level.
We talk about meaning as it
relates to communication.
So I'm a linguist
by education, so I
think about the semantic
layer, how we communicate
with one another, what we
convey across our communications
with one another.
You probably spend
a lot of your time,
if you do a lot of
development or engineering,
in patterns and significance.
That's probably a layer that
you spend a lot of time in.
But it could be all the way out
to the existential and cosmic
layer.
What is it all about, Alfie?
That sort of thing.
I think, in a sense,
it's almost like API
thinking for everything.
You can really think about
how one idea integrates
with another and how what
is meaningful on one side,
like the business side, can be
meaningful on the human side
of the equation.
How do you provide
hooks and intelligence
across those different
parts of the experience
and make sure that
that meaning is being
transferred through that layer?
The integration that most
brought me to this realization
is thinking about how the
design of experiences online now
regularly intersects with the
design of experiences offline,
that more and more as we think
about physical experiences,
they come with some sort
of digital component
or some sort of track
ability or traceability
with that physical experience.
Or when we think about
digital experiences,
we have to think about
the physical context
somebody might be in as they
encounter those interactions.
So I wrote about this in my
last book, "Pixels and Place."
So thinking about things
like the internet of things
and wearables and
beacons and sensors
and all kinds of
connected smart devices,
and how those bring
that connective layer
between those two worlds.
But the important
point about that
is that just about
everywhere interesting
that the physical
world and digital world
connect, that connection
layer happens through us,
through humans, through
our human experience.
It's our movements.
It's our behavior.
It's our patterns.
It's what we want, what we do,
what we indicate that really
creates that connection.
So again, it comes
back to thinking
about that integrated
human experience.
So I proposed this model in
"Pixels and Place," which
is integrated human experience
design, thinking about how
to blend those online
and offline contexts,
thinking about how to come
across all the different levels
and roles of humanity
that you might encounter,
thinking about how to
think about experience
in an integrated way,
interactions and transactions
across all the different touch
points that you might have.
And note the way I'm defining
the word design, which
is the adaptive execution
of strategic intent.
So you know you
have an intention.
You have a purpose
to what you're
trying to do with any
given design initiative.
And you know that you're
going to probably not get it
exactly where you want
it to be on the first go,
so we need to build an adaptive
iterative process to this.
And the more we do this
around a framework of creating
that meaningful interaction and
that dimensional relationship
between business,
entity, and human that's
consuming that
experience, the more
we stand a chance of conveying
some sort of meaningful truth.
So the elements of
integrated human experience
design, as described
in "Pixels and Place"--
I'll go through
it really quickly,
because what I want to get to
is that with "Tech Humanist,"
I've actually
built out upon this
to a more automated
understanding of experience.
But within integrated
human experience design
in "Pixels and Place," we look
at integration, of course.
That comes along for the ride.
So we're already talking
about all these layers
that are being integrated, the
online and offline contexts.
We're talking about
dimensionality.
So how does something
come to life
across different touch
points or ways in which you
interact with people?
How do the metaphors and
cognitive associations
come to life?
What sorts of intentional
things are you
communicating through all of
the choices that you're making,
about the language that you
use, the iconography you use,
and the cognitive assertions
you're bringing along
with that-- cognitive
associations you're
bringing along with that?
Intentionality and
purpose, so how
have you defined what it is
you're trying to accomplish?
And that comes into play at
a more holistic, macro level
as well, which we'll
get to in just a moment.
And a value and emotional
load, where are you
meeting someone in the world?
How challenging is that context?
If you're designing for an
encounter in a hospital,
for example, it's going to
be a very different type
of a value or emotional load
than if you encounter somebody
at a children's museum
where they're having fun--
hopefully, having fun.
Alignment is, of course,
that foundational principle
of understanding what
the business objective is
and understanding
the human objective
and making sure that they are
as tightly aligned as possible.
And then adaptation
and iteration being,
of course, that
process of making sure
that we are building
upon what we've learned,
we're using experimentation and
that mental model of building
our learnings as we go.
There's also this premise
that experience has,
in a sense, two layers to it.
If you think about human
nature as this ongoing truism,
like we all have,
throughout time,
needed to drink
water, for example.
But then there is this
shape of that experience
and how it gets packaged
up and dimensionalized.
And so you can see
this bottle of water
is an example of
saying, well, if I were
to put that water into
a heavy glass bottle
and label it with some sort
of minimalistic typeface brand
and create that whole aesthetic,
and it has this hipster
vibe to it, maybe
I'd feel like I'm
being a more aspirational
version of myself, because I'm
drinking maybe even the same
water out of this cool bottle.
And I feel like a
better version of who
I am than if I just drank it out
of the tap glass or whatever.
So there's this ongoing
way in which shapes evolve.
And it's important, I think,
to recognize that as we create
these integrated experiences,
that human experiences do
evolve, but the shapes will
always change more readily
than the nature.
And it helps us get into contact
and create this continuity
across time with the
human nature that
persists throughout
the experiences
that we're designing
for, and yet,
be ready to adapt to the
changing shape of experiences.
So with that, that leads
us into this opportunity
to think about how machine-led
experiences can actually
be more meaningful.
The more we're thinking
about automated experiences
and artificially
intelligent experiences,
how can we think about making
sure that the humans that
interact with those
are having as much
of a sense of meaning and
significance and dimension
to those?
So what I proposed
in "Tech Humanist"
is that we don't just
automate the menial.
We automate the meaningful.
I'll go through each one of
these in detail, of course.
That we automate empathy, that
we use human data respectfully,
and that we reinvest
the gains in efficiency
that we get in business
from automation
back into humanity and
human experiences, at least
at some level.
And so we'll talk about
each one of these.
I'll start with this.
I think a lot of times when
we talk about automation,
our base understanding is
that we should automate
menial, meaningless
things, so that humans
can do higher order tasks,
which is a nice enough premise,
until you start thinking
about that at scale
and start imagining a world in
which all kinds of functions
have been automated.
And most of our
world is automated
and most of our interactions
are with machines,
and they've all been
automated to be meaningless.
So I think it's a yes,
and, a both, and scenario.
We do need to think
about automating
the menial, meaningless
functions to free ourselves up
to think about
higher order things.
But we also need to think
about, what's working?
What are human
interactions that convey
some level of empathy
and nuance, that
create some sort of
significance and dimension?
And how can we work to
automate those as well?
How can we capture some
of that significance
in those automations?
So in this way, we're talking
about using data and technology
to scale, not just for
efficiency but for meaning,
to think about ways
that we can actually
create a sense of dimension
in the world around us.
One way that that works is--
I like to think about this
model of this relationship
between metaphor and metadata.
And I think the
easiest way to explain
this is a slide I
stole from Brian
Chesky, the CEO of Airbnb,
when he was demoing
a couple of years
ago, the new campaign
that they were launching
at the time, which
was the "Don't Go There,
Live There" campaign.
Anybody familiar with that?
Did you guys run
across that at all?
So the idea was, even if
it's only for one night,
go to every place you
visit as if you're a local,
treat that city
like you're a local.
And this slide was
an illustration
of how you could experience
a different type of approach
on TripAdvisor versus
with the Airbnb approach
of trusting the local experts.
So this is obviously Paris.
And note that
everything on each list
is different, except
for one, which
is the Luxembourg Garden, which
is my favorite place in Paris,
so yay, me.
Each of the other things
on the TripAdvisor list
is really just a brute
popularity contest.
It's all just, what are the most
bucket list items that someone
would associate with Paris?
And on the Airbnb
side, it's who has
the most significant
understanding
of the city of
Paris, what do they
recommend as being the places
that you must visit and must
experience in Paris?
And what I think
is interesting, is
when you think about the
metaphor that's really
underlying this, it's clear
that the TripAdvisor metaphor
is much more about
this casual tourist
experience of the world, this
conventional understanding.
Whereas the Airbnb
thing is that,
don't go there, live there,
this knowledge of the expertise.
And then the metadata clearly
is-- it's like the same city.
These are all the
same landmarks.
They exist in either case.
But one is being
rated for popularity,
and one is being ranked for
this expertise or authority.
So the way that these
two dimensions interact
with one another creates this
more meaningful understanding
of what the company
is trying to achieve
and how it brings it
to dimensional life
for the person that's
interacting with it.
Because that meaning
informs the purpose
that the company is bringing
to life in their experiences,
and the purpose of the
company that they're
trying to bring to life
fosters the meaning
that the person is going to
experience when they interact
with the touch points
that the company creates,
if they've done it well.
And the nice thing about this,
when you think about how this
really comes to life in an
automated, machine-led way,
is that humans really--
I think, when you think about
what the research shows,
what we most thrive on
is a sense of meaning
and common goals and a sense
of fulfilling something
bigger than ourselves.
Whereas machines thrive on this
sense of clear instruction.
And what leads to both of
those things is purpose.
Now, I'm not talking
about purpose
like in this touchy, feely,
spiritual sense, necessarily.
I'm talking about purpose as
a set of clear instructions
or a sense of clarity about what
it is you're trying to achieve.
And what that does is
leads to this ability
to bring all your resources to
bear in a very efficient way
and to align all
those resources,
to set priorities
very effectively
and make sure that everybody is
rowing in the same direction.
My favorite example
of this, of companies
setting a strategic
purpose and really
using it to operationalize
around, is Disney theme parks.
And from a digital
transformation perspective,
the MyMagic Band program--
how many of you have been
to Disney World or one
of the Disney theme parks
since they've introduced this?
It is pretty magical, right?
So they've articulated
their purpose statement as,
create magical experiences.
It's really just
those three words,
create magical experiences.
And so you think about
across the organization,
just about anyone
in any function
can understand how
they can solve problems
relative to their
scope of their work
as it relates to creating
more magical experiences.
A problem that's
brought to them,
they can just go, I
know how to solve this,
as long as the company actually
gets in line behind that
and allows them the autonomy
to solve the problem the way
they need to.
But think about
that as it relates
to digital transformation
and deploying
a billion dollar program, which
this was on that investment
scale for the company.
And you can do that with
complete confidence knowing
that this Magic Band is
going to allow people
to be able to go around the
park and use it as payment,
use it as access,
use it as preferences
on all kinds of information,
tracking that certainly gives
a lot of useful
information to the company
as they merchandise more
effectively and so on.
But that ability to
translate the purpose
into a deployment at
a billion dollar scale
is very clear from that program.
So we can design
experiences that
are aligned with
strategic purpose,
so that we can actually see that
understanding of purpose scale
to massive levels.
And purpose is the shape
meaning takes in business.
So that's how we get
that meaning to be felt
and understood at a human level.
By the way, I keep
talking about scale,
so I want to unpack
that a little bit, too.
So when we think about
creating meaningful experiences
at scale--
normally when we talk
about scale in a startup
or a corporate business, a
corporate growth scenario,
we are talking about
removing hard limits,
so that growth
opportunities can flourish.
And usually, we're talking about
that in terms of multiples,
let's say, like 3x
or 4x or 5x or 10x,
if you're very, very lucky.
But what happens
when a notion meets
nearly unlimited expansion
possibility, when
data can model it and
software can accelerate it
and automation can amplify
it and culture can adapt it?
And that's what,
really, we're talking
about with machine-led
experiences.
And that's why it's so important
that we think about creating
these in a more meaningful way.
Because if we don't create
the meaning into the system,
what are we doing?
We're allowing
absurdity to encroach,
and we don't want
absurdity to scale.
So my favorite example
of absurdity at scale
is one that--
I don't mean to knock the
program or the product,
because I think
it's incredible--
the Amazon Go store.
How many of you have
experienced it in person?
It's pretty cool, right?
The idea that you can actually
just walk into a grocery
store, you scan your
app as you go in
and then just pick up whatever
you need and walk right out.
And there's no
checking out process.
It just knows.
Through cameras and
sensors and so on,
it knows what you've
picked up and what
to associate with your
account, and you're good to go.
So obviously, we have to
talk about cashier jobs
and what that means for
the future of human work
as that goes to scale.
But let's leave that set
aside for just another moment,
because right now, what I'm
focused on is something else.
What happens when you open
the app for the first time
and you get this onboarding
that explains that,
as you pick things
up off the shelf,
the sensors know what
you've picked up.
And as you put it into
your basket or in your bag,
you'll be charged for it.
So it says, don't pick up
anything for anyone else, which
is fine, except that you
start thinking about,
I don't know about
you, but I get
asked all the time to
help people in stories.
You seem pretty tall.
You probably get asked for that.
You get asked.
And now, it's like,
well, I can't really
help that person to get
the thing off the shelf,
because it might
charge me for it.
And there's a way to
get it charged back,
and Amazon might fix this
before it goes to scale.
But really, 3,000
Amazon Go stores
have been announced before 2021.
So if this doesn't get fixed and
if it is something that we all
start adjusting our
behavior and not
helping other people
in the Amazon Go store,
well, that's the future of
retail we're talking about.
3,000 Amazon Go
stores by 2021 is
going to mean that retail
environments are going
to be this cashierless
environment before too long,
and so we won't help
each other in any stores.
And how long is it before we
don't help each other at all?
I know it sounds like
hyperbole at some level.
But what I mean to suggest is
that the idea that experience
at scale does change culture.
And I think that's important
to recognize, because really,
experience at scale is culture.
What we all collectively
agree to do with each other
and how we agree to interact
with each other is culture.
And all of the work that we
do creating human experiences
sets that context and
creates that modality,
so that understanding is
super, super important.
So I do have a slide here.
And if anybody
needs these slides,
I'm happy to share them.
But a slide that asks questions
and it's in the book as well.
If we were to try to deprogram
the absurdity of not helping
each other, we could
ask some questions
to step back from
that and think,
how do we not create
experience at scale
that's going to be absurd?
How do we make sure
that the brand isn't
going to be impacted
if we create
products or solutions
that might scale
in ways that are unexpected?
How do we pivot
to deal with that?
What does that look like?
So there's some questions we
can ask to anticipate that.
But primarily, I
think the challenge is
or the opportunity is
to think about meaning
and to think about keeping
absurdity from scaling.
This is a comic that
was drawn for me
by my friend Rob
Cottingham to illustrate
the opposite of tech humanism.
I don't know if you can read it.
It says, "It's getting
harder and harder
to hold on to my humanity.
But wow is it easy to track
my Amazon deliveries."
So of course, that's absurd.
But it's the idea that
we aren't thinking about,
what do we really want
meaningful experiences to look
like?
What do we really want our
future humanity to look like?
How do we create
technology solutions
that amplify our
humanity and don't
get in the way of humanity?
I think, that's really
what we're talking about.
The second premise of
machine-led meaningful human
experiences is to automate
empathy, which again, may sound
like it's a contradiction.
But I think there's
an opportunity
to think about the ways that
any kind of experience that we
design creates some
kind of connection
and to create as meaningful
a connection as possible.
So how many of you remember
the "Seinfeld" episode
where Kramer got a
new phone number,
and it was one digit
off from Moviefone?
Anybody remember this?
So anybody remember Moviefone?
I know the app just
ended as of a week ago.
But in the '80s and
'90s or whatever,
we all had to pick up the
phone and actually call
a service to tell us
what movies were playing.
And in this episode, Kramer
had gotten a new phone number.
It was one digit
off from Moviefone.
And it's obviously
touch tone service,
so he couldn't understand
the touch tones.
He decided that he was going
to impersonate Moviefone.
But he couldn't understand
the touch tones,
so he ends up just saying,
why don't you just tell me
what movie you want to see.
And I find this to be
such a prescient example
of how we think about
machine-driven interactions
and how we think about what
human-based interactions look
like, the relationship
between those two.
So I think of the
Moviefone, Kramer model
as agile deployment of
emerging technology.
That you can think about
the robotic interaction
and the human interaction
as being somehow
interchangeable
with one another,
so that you can actually
use human interaction
to gather patterns that
you will encode as chatbots
or other types of automation.
And not to suggest
that you would lie,
that you would present
a human and have
it be posing as Moviefone or
whatever your equivalent is,
but rather, that you
would have some kind
of agile human-based
interaction that
gives you the insights
to be able to create
scripts and create patterns
that help you develop frameworks
for automation.
And of course, you're starting
with if, then statements.
But you're quickly trying
to work beyond the if,
then to get to the nuance.
So if, then is
easy to anticipate,
in the kind of frequently asked
questions model of automation.
If you're automating, let's
say, a chatbot for a bank,
you know that a lot
of your interactions
are going to be about how
to change your password,
for example, or how to
set up a new account.
So if someone wants to
create a new account,
then here's the answer and
here's the flow diagram
that you can walk them through.
But the nuance beyond that is,
I need to change my password,
because my ex is stalking me,
and it's a dangerous situation.
And there needs to be some
human interaction there.
There needs to be some human
nuance to that experience.
So that's more where the
empathy gets automated
into the process, is finding
those types of interactions
and finding the
opportunity to build out
the relationship between
the automated and the human.
And also, when we're
looking for patterns,
that we're not just looking
for arbitrary patterns
and encoding those.
Arbitrariness also
sits in opposition
to meaningfulness in much
the same way that absurdity
sits in opposition
to meaningfulness.
So we want to make
sure that we're
finding meaningful patterns
and automating those.
Because in all of the
work that we do with this,
we cannot leave
meaning up to machines.
Machines won't do meaning.
That's just not something that
machines are really equipped
for.
So it has to be humans that
determine what is meaningful.
And I love this example.
I know many of you probably work
around image recognition or AI,
and so you know this
dilemma very, very well.
I know a lot of algorithms
have advanced since this day.
The puppy versus muffin
problem is one of my faves,
and it always gets a chuckle.
I see some smiles
in the audience.
But it's true,
that subtle nuances
aren't really where AI shines,
in many cases at this point,
at least not at a meaningful
recognition level,
not being able to say
that the muffins all
have this certain meaningful
characteristic and the human,
the puppies all have
this certain meaningful
characteristic.
Whereas, I believe many
of you are probably
able to determine
which one's a muffin
and which one's a
puppy pretty well.
Here's some more, by the way.
You know which one's a barn
owl and which one's an apple.
You're not having any
trouble with that, I bet--
which one's a croissant.
But I think this
introduces an idea
that there may be
opportunities for humans
to work alongside
machines in ways
that add nuance and
empathy and understanding
to the machine-led processes,
because humans generally
do nuance pretty well.
That's something that
we are encoded for.
We get meaning.
That's what we're
about, so we're
able to add that into
the value proposition.
So when we think about the
relationship between machines
and humans as we move
into the future of work
and the future of
that economy, I
think we're going to add the
most value by being human
and understanding
meaning and nuance
and understanding value and
understanding each other
and adding that layer
to those interactions.
So the third tenet of the
machine-led meaningful
experience is to use
human data respectfully.
It comes from this
idea that when
we talk about digital
transformation,
I kind of feel like that's
a little bit of a misnomer
at some level,
because we already
made a digital transformation
the moment we started spending
all of our time in
front of screens,
transacting in bits and
bytes with each other.
So that's kind of a done deal.
And what's really
more meaningful
than that is the data
transformation, the fact
that all of this is happening
with a data layer behind it,
that business has all
kinds of data visibility
and transparency through
the supply chain,
through logistics,
through operations.
And everything has this
clarity and transparency
about what kind of track ability
is going on, what's measurable
and all that.
So it's a really interesting
layer to work with.
But when we talk about digital
transformation, including
automation and
digitization, all of that,
all of the many nuances
of that, fundamentally
what we're talking about
is agility with data.
As companies become more
digitally ready and digitally
transformed, they're
becoming more agile
with database decisions.
And that data that we're talking
about is really our data.
It's human data.
For the most part, business
data is largely about people.
It's our purchases.
It's our movements
through space.
It's our preferences.
It's all of our tastes and
indications that we've made.
And really, what I'm saying
is analytics are people.
At some level,
for the most part,
when we are looking at
graphs and reports and so on,
we're generally looking
at the needs and interests
and motivations of real
people that are there
buying from our companies
and interacting with them
and driving all of
these decisions for us.
And I think the flip side of
appreciating that and treating
that data with respect
is understanding
that what we encode
into machines
is really about us, that
we are putting ourselves
and our biases
into the encoding,
into the algorithms and
everything that we create.
So the opportunity,
I think, as we
look at this tech
humanist future,
is to encode the
best of ourselves,
is to think about
how we can create
our most egalitarian
viewpoints and our most
evolved understandings
into the data we model,
into the algorithms we
build, and into the automated
experiences that we
design and create.
So we can use our human data to
make more meaning in the world.
And we can recognize that
the more we create relevance
in the alignment
between business
objectives and human
objectives, the more we
are creating a form of respect.
But the caveat to that
is that discretion
is a form of respect, too,
that we're also allowing people
to, say, be forgotten
by us and allowing them
to take their data with them,
and that we can not make people
feel like we're
creeping them out
by knowing so much about them.
And that we protect
human data excessively,
that we make sure we're
being very, very, very
careful with the data
that we collect and use
in business decisions,
because we recognize
that it is human data.
The last point-- and
it's a quick one,
because this may or may not be
within scope for many of you.
But that as we think
about the gains
that we make in our
businesses through automation
and machine-led experiences,
that we think about reinvesting
some of those gains into how
to create more meaningful
human experiences at scale.
And I don't think it's
really a mystery why
that's so important.
There was a study done,
a couple of versions
of a study done on what
jobs are potentially
considered automatable.
And this is one visualization
of the data from that study
that shows the different
cities in the United States
and how likely the
jobs that are there
are to be automated
over the coming years.
I zoomed in on New York,
which is where I'm from,
and you see 55% of
jobs are considered
potentially automatable.
And you have to think about the
socioeconomic impact of that.
You have to think about the
psychological impact of that,
that humans have had a very
deeply connected experience
to work, that we've derived
a lot of our sense of meaning
and identity from work.
We say who we are in
terms of what we do,
and we have names like butcher,
baker, tanner, carpenter,
and so on, that derive
from ancestral jobs, that
have been carried down through
generations of our family.
And that's true across cultures.
So it's a really important
thing to understand,
that jobs are going to change.
There's going to be job
displacement, augmentation,
and replacement by automation.
And we don't yet know what
that means for human meaning,
and we don't yet know what
that means economically.
We don't yet know what that
means sociopolitically.
And so there's a huge
opportunity for us
to take the gains that
we make in automation
and have this ethical
contribution back into society,
back to humanity
and say, what can we
do to foster a sense of meaning
and a sense of community
and a sense of connectedness
and a sense of more
humanity with those gains?
So I think we can also think
about repurposing human skills
and qualities into
higher value roles.
One of the executives that was
in a strategic workshop I led
ran a utilities company
in South America.
And he found, through
our work, an opportunity
to automate a customer
service function that
was their most heavily
accessed customer support
question and function.
And once he saw
that opportunity,
he saw that there was a
way to take the humans that
were working in that job and
create oversight positions
for them, so that
they could continue
training the algorithms
that were going
to create that automation.
So obviously, a very
straightforward kind
of replacement, it may
not be a one-for-one.
We may see job loss anyway.
But some of that
reinvestment is going
to offer up higher
value human roles.
So here are those
four tenets again.
And I think the summary of
this really comes back to,
as you think about the
work you're trying to do
and how to create these
more meaningful experiences
through automation and through
artificial intelligence
and so on, it really comes
down to this question of,
what is it that you are
trying to do at scale?
So that's the purpose statement.
How can you
articulate what it is
your company is trying to do,
your team is trying to do,
you are trying to do at scale?
And for me, the answer
to that question
is, create more meaningful
human experiences.
It's just as simple as that.
But the way that
I can do that is
by speaking with
groups like yourself,
working with executives,
working with leaders
and being able to help them
hone in on that purpose
and really get clearer on
how to create those more
meaningful experiences
that do align the business
objectives with the human
objectives, that do bring
the business results and
that create a better future
for humanity.
So because business will have
to scale through digitization
and automation, business
won't be successful long term
without it, it's table stakes.
But humanity won't be
successful without meaning.
So for that, I thank all of
you for the work that you do.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM: Thanks, Kate.
We have a Dory.
There no questions
on it right now,
so we can ask a few
local questions.
And if anything shows up, then
we'll get those included, too.
But I see a hand right here
and can we get a mic over--
SPEAKER: I have the
mic, test, test, test.
Sounds good.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
the talk, first off.
So for the rhetorical
question you
asked at the very
beginning of the talk,
I know a lot of people,
if not most people
I know, would answer, a soul.
What makes humans
human is a soul.
So what advice would you give
about how to automate religion?
KATE O'NEILL: It's a very
interesting question.
I actually have talked with
a few people about the work
that they're doing
around automation
and creating experiences
for people at scale
around religion.
And I don't feel like I'm
in a really good position
to be an expert on that.
It's not the work that I do.
But I do think that religion is
fundamentally offering meaning,
so really, we're talking
about the same principles.
We're talking about being
able to offer people
a lens into what is meaningful
and then helping to scale that.
So if there is a solution that
someone is trying to build,
that is some sort of
technology product for creating
a religious experience or a
religious outlet for people
or community, then I
think it really comes down
to the same principles.
It's just like religion is
the industry, in that sense,
and we're trying
to offer meaning
through those experiences.
That would be, probably,
my best take on that.
But I think it's a more
interesting question than that
at some fundamental
layer, and it
sounds like a discussion over
beers or something like that.
So do we have another question?
Yes, to your left.
AUDIENCE: Hi,
thanks for the talk.
I was really struck
by your point
about shared experiences
forming culture.
And obviously, we in
the technology world,
have a lot of increasingly
shape shared experience.
So in the Amazon Go point about
people not helping each other,
that's something
we can all probably
agree is a net negative.
And even Amazon, I'm
sure, would agree.
But there's a lot of cases
where we have the potential
to shape culture, where the
answer really isn't clear,
what is the right thing to
do, filter bubbles being one
controversial idea,
whether they're
a good thing or a bad thing.
So I'm wondering, what's
your take on how we
should approach these problems?
What principle should we use in
deciding how to shape culture
or what processes or
institutions maybe we
need to make these decisions?
KATE O'NEILL: Thank you, it's
a really good and big question.
I'd like to cop out and say
that the entire book, "Tech
Humanist," addresses it.
But at some level,
what it comes down
to is trying to understand
that strategic purpose,
that alignment between business
objective and human objective.
And I think, if you're
looking at a filter bubble
type of example as one
example of something
where a social platform or an
online community or a media
company is fostering through
algorithmic content filtering
and so on, this
sense of disparity
between people's collective
understanding of what is truth,
I think you can probably
come to some understanding
at some level of view of that.
The business objective, which
may be advertising or something
along those lines, and the human
objective aren't aligned there.
So I do think that there is
still a useful framework there,
but I do offer some additional
ones in "Tech Humanist"
as well.
It is a really good
and important question.
And it's an important
point for us
all, I think, to
consider in the work
that we're doing,
because there are
so many net positives and
net goods that come out of,
let's say, with social
media and the connectedness
we have with each
other and the way we're
able to maintain relationships
with such ease versus 20
years ago.
But of course, it does come with
these associated difficulties
and the challenges
of making sure
that we're all speaking the same
language, which at the moment,
I believe we're not.
We were having that
discussion beforehand.
So I'm going to
leave it at that.
I think there's a lot in
the book, which I'll just
keep pointing back to
that, that does unpack that
a little further.
But I genuinely think that that
framework of understanding what
it is the business is
trying to accomplish
and what it is that's good for
humanity, how those things can
be in line.
And it doesn't have to come
down to a humanitarian purpose.
It just has to
mean that we're not
accelerating
something that is not
ultimately good for humanity.
That, I think, is where the
alignment comes back to.
TIM: There's a
question on the Dory
and it's similar to a
question that I had.
So I'm going to try to
merge them together.
The question on the
Dory starts like this.
Scale tends to force humans
to reduce their variety
to adapt to machines instead
of the other way around.
So further, what about
ways to reduce scale that
are compatible with business?
You mention distributism,
decentralization, or something
else.
And I'll add that
I think that a lot
of this technological change
is really coercive, meaning,
either you get
with it or you get
left out, particularly
around the job changes
that you talked about.
And how much is
our responsibility
to bring people along,
like to offer the lifeboat,
and how much do people really
need to get in the boat?
KATE O'NEILL: I think that's
a really difficult thing
to be able to break down
in one side or the other.
I think that the change
is coming no matter what.
What we find,
though, is the change
is going to be
disproportionately felt.
So jobs that are most
likely to be automated
are jobs like truck driver,
cashier, these types of things.
And what we know is
that statistically,
those jobs are
disproportionately
held by people of
color, so that not fair,
not equal distribution
is happening.
So I think we do
have an obligation.
If we're trying to create
the best futures for the most
people, which is
what I would say
is one of the underpinning
ideas or underlying ideas
of "Tech Humanist," that we
have to be thinking about how
to create a more equitable
distribution of opportunity
and how to make sure that
the impact of automation
is not going to destroy one
set of human's potential
while it increases the potential
for enrichment of another.
So that inequity is going
to become even more extreme
than we've already experienced.
So I think it's in our
best interest as humans
to think about how to shift
that or how to level that out.
Not that people
can't become wealthy,
but that we don't create this
even more extreme distribution
than we already have.
So I think to some extent,
it's imperative for anyone
who's creating experiences,
which is pretty much everyone
that works in technology,
that works around most fields
that I've worked around, health
care, entertainment, and so
on, to think about the
change that's coming
and how to make
sure that it is--
that we are creating as much
opportunity there as possible.
But yes, I think there's also
this kind of new emerging
space around opportunities
to retrain people
and repurpose, get people
to understand the new skills
that they might have.
I shared some really great
stats in "Tech Humanist"
about programs that
were taking, let's say,
prisoners who had come
out of prison programs
and been able to retrain them
into communities, the jobs
that they could keep.
And there was 0.1% recidivism
within this program,
so I'd urge you to
look into that example.
There's just so many ways that
I think an ecosystem of answers
is really what's going on here.
We have to own
the responsibility
as content creators and
experience creators.
And we also have to
recognize that this
is going to be a
broadly distributed,
broadly felt thing that is
going to have inequity to it.
TIM: So to bring back a word
that Paul put in his question,
decentralization, how does
maybe decentralization help
with this by spreading power
around or control around?
Maybe just talk about
decentralization for a bit.
KATE O'NEILL: Well, I think the
idea of spreading power around
and spreading control
around is interesting.
Certainly, we have seen, through
user-generated content, user
communities, and platforms
like Meetup, for example,
we were talking about
earlier, as one way that there
are tools that we can put in
the hands of people that allow
people to create communities
amongst themselves,
create more human connection.
Those are going to be, I
think, increasingly important.
And the technologies are
there to foster that and allow
discovery within
those communities,
allow people to find each
other and connect more deeply.
But I think we just have
to be thinking mindfully
about the challenge of not
amplifying those net negatives,
as your question was alluding to
earlier with the filter bubble
and so on.
So I'd love to hear more
specifically what about
decentralization might be--
what's nagging on the person's
mind that's asking the question
or on your mind.
So whoever is asking
that, feel free to ask
a secondary question.
TIM: If they call.
KATE O'NEILL: And if
there's any other--
TIM: Or maybe for
the sake of time,
we look for one more question
in the room before we wrap up.
Anything else?
Yes.
KATE O'NEILL: Great.
AUDIENCE: So I have
a thought about some
of this stuff in terms of,
do you ever take your work
and look at it as
a lens of looking
at humanity through the
lens of what technology
is revealing about people?
KATE O'NEILL: Yeah.
I have looked at that.
But I'm very curious
as to what is occurring
to you as you think about that.
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean, I
used to do a lot of community
management, and so I came
out of being on the BBSs back
in the late '80s, early '90s.
And so it's this
thing where I realized
that a lot of what
happened online was just
what happened offline
but at a different scale
and at different localities.
And that was an
aha moment for me
when I was a part of these
little communities back
in the BBS days.
So it's just kind of like as
technology has become more
and more prevalent in
our lives, it's something
that I kind of look
at, almost flip
the conversation a little
bit in my own head of like,
what does it mean--
what does it say about
people given how we're using?
KATE O'NEILL: A
little bit of that
points back to the
decentralization discussion,
as well.
But I like the aspect
you brought up.
One of the aspects of
this that I have looked at
is that it seems to me
that our digital selves,
that aggregate set of
characteristics that gets
collected through our movements,
through our connections,
through our interactions
in social spheres,
that digital self is really
our aspirational self mostly,
and that we are saying
who we most want to be.
And it seems ironic to
me that that digital self
is the self, the
version of ourselves,
that is most
commodified by business
and most capitalized upon
and manipulated by business.
I think in our physical
manifestations,
we are much less prone to
that kind of manipulation
and over-capitalization.
Yet, this digital self, which
is our aspirational self,
is prone to that.
So I think this is
the opportunity for us
to merge that understanding
and say, well, it
is a human that we're looking
at in that digital, collected,
aggregate data points,
and so we need to be
respectful about that too.
So I think that flipped
version is to say,
there's this way that
we're interacting
with each other in a
way that represents
who we most want to be and
who we most feel we are.
So it's all the
more reason why we
need to be respectful
with the data
that we collect and
monetize and use
within business to inform
our intelligent decisions
and our systems.
So I'd say that
that's exciting to me.
TIM: Thank you, Kate.
And thanks, Google, for being
a great audience for Kate.
And I guess we owe a
solid round of applause.
So thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
And Kate, especially.